WHERE IS IT?
JOINING NOW PAM BONDI'S WITH US
FOR COMMENTARY AS WELL AS
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT.
YOUR TAKE ON ALL OF THIS?
>> HAVING PERSONALLY AS A
PROSECUTOR FOR 18 YEARS SIGNED
THOUSANDS OF SUBPOENAS,
THOUSANDS THEM A MANY TIMES
PEOPLE DON'T COMPLY.
YOU EITHER ISSUE A NEW SUBPOENA
OR DO A MOTION TO COMPEL.
WHY WAS THAT NOT DONE IN THIS
CASE?
THE TRUMP PEOPLE WERE WORKING
WELL WITH THEM AND WHY WASN'T
THAT DUMB?
THAT'S A QUESTION
FOR MERRICK GARLAND.
NUMBER TWO, THE WARRANT, THINK
ABOUT THE WARRANTS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ISSUE A
WARRANT, THE REASON HAS TO BE
I'M WORRIED THEY ARE GOING TO
DESTROY EVIDENCE.
WHAT SUSPECT ABOUT THAT IS THAT
WE LEARNED THAT THE WARRANT WAS
SIGNED ON FRIDAY, BUT NOT
EXECUTED UNTIL MONDAY.
WHY GET THE WARRANT?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
I'VE PERSONALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
MANY, MANY SEARCH WARRANTS
AUTHORIZING THEM, THE EXECUTION
OF THE SEARCH WARRANT AND THEY
CAME IN WITH GUNS BLAZING LIKE
YOU SAID.
FOR DOCUMENTS, YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
DO?
YOU GO UP AND SHOW THE WARRANT
AT MAR-A-LAGO, THEY KNEW THE
PRESIDENT WASN'T THERE, IT'S A
SKELETON CREW AND YOU GO IN AND
YOU GO TO THE SAFE, THE OFFICE,
GET THE DOCUMENTS YOU NEED.
IT DONE.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY DID AN EXECUTION ON LAND,
SEE YOU, BY AIR.
IF THEY HAD AGENTS IN THE WATER,
AGENTS IN THE AIR, YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN 30 OR 40 ON THE GROUND, BUT
THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF AGENTS
THAT HAD TO BE WEAPONIZE TO PUL.
OF THAT DAY AND THAT NIGHT.
MERRICK GARLAND, THAT'S WHERE
TAX DOLLARS ARE GOING?
DID YOU SEE THE MASSIVE TRUCKS
OUT THERE LINED AROUND.
IT WAS THE OPTICS, THEY THOUGHT
DONALD TRUMP WOULD LOOK LIKE A
COMMON CRIMINAL BUT IT BACKFIRED
ON THEM AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
AND THEY ARE DISGUSTED BY THIS.
HE'S GOT LOT MORE EXPLAINING TO
DO.
>> Sean: LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID
TO PETER NAVARRO, LOOK AT WHAT
THEY DID TO PAUL MANAFORT, ROGER
JOINING US TONIGHT.
THIS IS THEIR TACTIC HOW THEY
WANT TO HARASS, INTIMIDATE, SEND
A MESSAGE TO EVERYBODY ELSE
DON'T MESS WITH US.
WE ARE ALL POWERFUL AND
ALMIGHTY.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD, THE DUAL
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE COULDN'T BE
MORE CLEAR THAN IT IS NOW.
>> I DON'T QUESTION THE
INTEGRITY OF THE DOJ AND THE
FBI, I CRITICIZE THE OTHER LACK
OF INTEGRITY OF MERRICK GARLAND
AND CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
MERRICK GARLAND UNWITTINGLY AND
STUPIDLY UNDERMINED HIS OWN
ARGUMENT WHEN HE SAID OUR
STANDARD PRACTICE IS TO USE THE
LEAST INTRUSIVE METHODS.
IF THAT'S A SUBPOENA.
THE FBI DID THAT TWO MONTHS AGO.
THEY WERE COUNTING ON
DONALD TRUMP CHALLENGING IT SO
THAT THEY WOULD THEN BE POISED
FOR A RAID.
BUT TRUMP CAPITULATED AND GAVE
THEM EVERYTHING THEY WANTED SO
THEY PROBABLY SAT BACK AT THE
DOJ AND SAID WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO DO?
THEY SHOULD HAVE ISSUED ANOTHER
SUBPOENA IF THEY WANTED MORE
DOCUMENTS.
I SUSPECT ALL OF THAT IS LEFT
OUT OF THE AFFIDAVIT IN SUPPORT
OF THE FBI WARRANT TO SEARCH THE
PREMISES.
I THINK THEY PROBABLY BRIBED TO
THIS MAGISTRATE WHICH IS NOT A
REGULAR FEDERAL COURT JUDGE,
APPOINTED BY THE DISTRICT JUDGE
TO DO THE GRUNT WORK.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
AND A REAL JUDGE WOULD HAVE SAID
WAIT A MINUTE.
YOU'RE SEARCHING THE PREMISES?
>> Sean: WHY DIDN'T HE RECUSE
HIMSELF HERE?
DANGEROUS TIMES.
>> THE SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS WERE
VIRULENTLY ANTI-TRUMP AND HE'S
REQUIRED TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
A GOOD JUDGE WOULD HAVE SAID
WAIT A MINUTE.
WHY AREN'T YOU USING A SUBPOENA?
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE MAGISTRATE HIMSELF.